the US has condemned the Iran's seizure
of an oil tanker in the Gulf of Oman the
tanker is reported to been bordered by
armed Intruders near the Omani Coast
before its tracking device was turned
off and it turned towards Iran it's
carrying more than 100,000 tons of crude
oil the vessel is called the St Nicholas
and it was seized by the United States
last year over sanctions imposed on Iran
abas Sani is a journalist and Senior
research fellow at the center for Middle
East strategic studies in tan and he's
joining us live from there good to have
with us on aler why would Iran seize
this
tanker uh well this development seems to
have two Dimensions one that is related
to the uh flexing of muscles between
Iran the UN and the United States over
the uh implementation of economic
sanctions against Iran uh La back in
April 2023 the United States confiscated
Iranian oil that was being carried by
the same old tanker but uh The Vessel
was crossing the Sea of Oman that's why
at this uh timing Iran seized the tanker
uh the second dimension is related to
the let's say the Gaza War which is
ongoing and we have been seeing that
yemenis recently they have been trying
to Target uh vessels link to Israel in
order to put pressure on Tel Aviv to
stop the uh attacks on the people of
Gaza but the United States now seems to
be helping Israelis in order to put
pressure on yemenis and uh let's say
this these two issues you know uh
combined together can be somehow more
meaningful within this context I mean
the US has pulled together a
multinational force it says and it's
involving several different um vessels
from from different fleets in order to
be able to try and protect uh um
shipping from attacks by houthis in
Yemen is there a risk do you think that
an action like this could be perceived
as a provocation that it might actually
intensify the situation in the
region uh well we have been seeing some
moves by Israelis and the United States
which have been provocative against Iran
and recently as you stated you know the
the Americans want to create a kind of
Coalition against yemenis and the
houthis uh because they think that the
attacks by huis have been putting
pressure on Israel and and it it has
created risks for the transit uh of the
ships in the region uh that's why you
know these kind of actions and reactions
could create a kind of escalation and it
seems that the both sides try to play
the game at the high level of pressure
and to push to the limits of the other
sides in order let's say to stop uh the
oppos in side and that's why I think uh
this could somehow be interp interpreted
within the context of the Gaza War uh
one side wants to stop the war the other
side wants to uh support Israelis and
that's why this is part of the game both
parties trying to pressure each other y
just very briefly I wanted to was there
was a statement that came out from the
the company Tas in in in Tura that was
saying that they Nas was carrying Iraqi
crude oil from Iraq is there a risk do
you think that as a result of that this
is going to bring Iraq as another um
element if you like into a very
difficult situation and make it a
triumverate between the US and
Iran well I think this could be quite
understandable for the Iraqi government
as well as the Turkish one because they
know that this is a ret retaliation
against the moves by the United States
against Iran and not against Bagdad or
anara uh so Iran wants to make sure and
clear that if even Americans confiscate
Iranian oil they have to uh pay the
price and this could be quite meaningful
ahead of the uh presidential election
the United States and Iran wants to
somehow you know uh make American
Administration to understand that if
they want to uh create a con of
escalation as they are approaching to
the election uh so this could have kind
of let's say surprises for them this
could bring up you know uh
escalation uh so this could be
interpreted from this perspective I
think AB San we appreciate you joining
us and Al thank you very much
indeed welcome thank you